thanks to private internet access for
helping support this episode
hey crazies have you ever noticed how
wonky black holes look like why does
this thing curve up here why does this
stick out the bottom what makes this
part brighter and this part dimmer why
is there a Gap here what is this ring
and where is the actual black hole in
this picture all of those questions can
be answered with a little black hole
anatomy and some Optics
[Music]
to be as clear as possible black holes
are the blackest black that ever blacked
we can't actually see them most of what
you're seeing when you look at one is
the accretion disk
the accretion disk is what stuff becomes
as it begins its descent into the black
hole accretion is just a fancy word for
growth by gradual buildup in this case
it's the gradual accumulation of matter
anything that gets close to a black hole
is going to get ripped apart and heated
tidal forces do the ripping and then
friction within the disc does the
heating up to like 18 million degrees
Fahrenheit this stuff is made of plasma
just like stars it's that hot and it's
revolving around the black hole at a
significant fraction of the speed of
light fast fast its speed is so high
that Einstein's relativity predicts a
change in apparent brightness the part
of the accretion disk moving toward us
appears brighter and the part moving
away appears dimmer an effect we call
Doppler beaming
technically it happens at all speeds but
it's only noticeable near light speed
fast fast and in case you're wondering
we have observed it in an actual image
too it's not just a prediction anymore
but why does it look so wonky Optics
Optics is the study of the behavior of
light especially how light interacts
with matter the accretion disk is
actually flat it's always in the
equatorial plane of the black hole but
when we take pictures of these discs
they don't look flat parts of it kind of
curve up here and some of it sticks out
the bottom down here that's just an
optical illusion though the images we
see whether that be with our eyes or
with a camera are made with light and
light doesn't always travel in what we
would instinctively consider to be
straight lines you know how when you
look into a mirror and it kind of seems
like you're looking through a window and
a clone of yourself if light traveled in
straight lines at all times you wouldn't
see anything in a mirror but some of the
light scattering off your body hits this
reflective surface and bounces it
doesn't really bounce but you get the
idea some of that light reflects and
enters your eyes allowing you to see
something that isn't in your field of
view you see an image where No Object
exists but at least that image looks
like you
to get a distortion more like a black
hole you'd have to look into something
like a fun house mirror those make the
light go in unexpected directions a
similar thing is happening with the
light from the accretion disk except
it's not a reflection gravity only
affects Mass though right actually
that's not true what gravity may come
from Mass but it affects everything even
light
gravity is not a force it's a
fundamental change in what straight
lines look like take these straight
lines for example with something like a
planet or a star those same lines would
look like this there's only a slight
deviation and the path light would take
like a fraction of a degree near a black
hole the change is much more dramatic
paths could easily turn through
significant angles the light being bent
by a black hole doesn't have to come
from a great distance though let's say
it came from the accretion disk the path
still bends and the light is sent off to
its destination our detectors those
detectors treat the light as though it
didn't bend and they see a distorted
image you know how we can't see the back
of Saturn's rings because Saturn is in
the way well this is what Saturn's rings
would look like with the same Distortion
you can see the back the accretion disc
is actually flat but we don't see it as
flat because of the weird Optics
does this make me a flat accretion
disker
while he's thinking hard about that
let's take a moment to think this
video's sponsor private internet access
they're a VPN or virtual private Network
which sends your internet traffic
through something they call an encrypted
tunnel but do you need a VPN well
information you exchange with websites
is usually already encrypted by
something like SSL that's what this lock
symbol means but your IP address is
still visible which allows websites to
serve you location-based ads charge you
different prices and even sometimes give
you a different quality of service
seriously streaming services show you a
different catalog based on your location
private internet access can mask your IP
address so you can watch your favorite
shows like say Star Trek no matter where
you are but you might want to check your
streaming services terms of use before
you try this they can be sticklers and
I'd hate for your account to get banned
anyway think of a VPN as using a PO Box
to receive your mail instead of using
your home address private internet
access has servers in over 84 different
countries in every single US state so
it's like getting to move that PO Box
around on a whim if that sounds like
something you'd be interested in sign up
with the link in the description below
you'll get 83 off in four extra months
completely free thanks again to private
internet access for helping support this
episode
moving on
I'm not sure if you've noticed yet but
that accretion disk does not go all the
way into the center there's a limit
called the innermost stable circular
orbit or Isco for short every individual
particle in the disk is on a decaying
orbit around the black hole but its
orbital speed is helping Stave off the
fall so the Decay is gradual that all
ends when the particle reaches Isco at
that point no speed is fast enough the
particle Falls in no no no no no no
that's why we see a gap here massive
particles can't orbit any closer than
this but massless particles like photons
can light can orbit a black hole yep
there's a special distance where the
paths of light turn into circles that's
what we call the photon sphere light
orbits the black hole at this distance
of course if that light were perfectly
bound we wouldn't see it what we're
actually seeing is the light just
outside the photon sphere that light
gradually spirals outward until it
finally escapes that's the photon ring
found here so the photon ring is the
outer edge of the photon sphere well not
quite don't forget the optical
distortions and those distortions get
more pronounced the closer we get to the
black hole this ring might be made of
photons from the photon sphere but the
photon sphere itself is closer in again
Optics assume straight lines so this
escaping light appears to come from here
it's just an image of the photon Sphere
not the photon sphere itself
inside the photon ring we see nothing
that's what we call the black hole
Shadow but it's not it's not really a
shadow a shadow implies something is in
the way blocking the light that's not
what's happening with a black hole this
so-called Shadow is just an image of the
Event Horizon that Horizon just happens
to be black
if there was some hypothetical skin
around that Horizon with lights we would
be able to see that light coming from
that skin would still have its paths
bent though we'd not only be able to see
the front of the Event Horizon but also
the back but it gets even weirder than
that
some of the light goes around several
times so you'd see the front of the
Event Horizon in the middle of the
Shadow and then the back warped around
that and then the front again and then
the back again and so on in a set of
repeated and increasingly thinner Rings
filling the shadow space
physics predicted the size of the Shadow
it predicted a gap between the orbits of
light and matter it even predicted what
that would ultimately look like from a
distance in appearance so weird it's
easy to be skeptical but then we took a
picture and the physics was correct our
instincts are what's wrong and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy
many of you were wondering how some
black holes could be less dense than air
I mean it's not like there's a lot of
them out there they got to be really big
big even for the supermassive kind but
it's because the black hole's diameter
is proportional to its mass you should
work it out yourself it's really fun
anyway thanks for watching
no no no no no no